did you do doctor who too
how many episodes i did uh two
episodes at the beginning of season six
do you still get people coming up to you
for doctor girls
it's wonderful it was in nixon's white
house during the uh
space race really oh god yeah and i'm
playing a
uh
a former fbi agent
do you know i've never seen doctor who
it's fantastic i'll i'll tell you where
to start to what i mean which doctor do
i start with no well
the thing is what you grew up with is
your doctor right but me personally it's
not a bad place to start isn't it not to
go into monster of the week stuff but
but there is a really interesting arc
that starts with fish fingers and
custard you can do this for him
when matt smith starts at fish fingers
and custard goes through pandorica
through christmas
into the stuff i did in season six which
is written by neil gaiman written by
mark gaidis written by some of the best
people so you watched a lot of episodes
no more than anything else i mean i've
watched doctor who was a kid
so they kind of they came to me if it
wasn't for jim michaels supernatural i
wouldn't have been able to do it they
flipped a schedule around in england so
i could do it they offered it to me and
i was like of course and they said when
are you coming over to the prosthetics
as the older me that'll make sense to
you when you see it
um
and i said why don't you just ask my dad
that's right so he goes
would he do it of course he'd do it so i
called my dad and i go like you're doing
doctor who and he's like he didn't even
ask him just said you're doing doctor he
goes is it all cardboard and bits of
string like it used to be you know for
sets i'm like no it's fabulous and i
sent him the same stuff that i'm telling
you about
and he watched matt smith he was god
this boy is incredible
beautiful actor
and he suddenly got that
thing
of why it's so precious to so many
people wow so he played you older you've
played the older me
what a genius thing and he had to do it
in utah so he had to get dispensation
from sag to do it as non-union oh my god
just tell morgan here
i've got to do this thing but it's
non-union you want a waiver i don't know
do i want morgan you want a waiver you
want to oh okay fine then i want a
waiver
you